two years away from a potential nfl work
stoppage and there's been multiple
indications that there's reason for hope
when it relates to the talks on a new
cba the nflpa pushing back a little bit
yesterday by advising all agents to tell
their players to save enough money to be
able to get through a work stoppage that
would last at least one full year chris
i'll ask you since you went through some
of these stages during your time in the
nfl do you really think today's players
are wired to miss game checks and wired
to miss the opportunity to do the thing
they love to do which is play football
no i don't you know i think that the
today's player and you and i talk about
this a lot is more educated on the
business aspects of the nfl more than
ever before and they understand that
component and i think they want to
drive a tough bargain you know but the
other the problem is this and yes you're
i mean you're right i went through this
now i was fortunate to getting ready to
go into this which was that what was
that right before the 2010 season am i
right about that you know i had made
enough money to where i wasn't panicked
at that time okay gosh if we don't play
a year i've saved enough and made enough
you know in the first six seven years of
my career where i'll be okay of course
would rather have checks but it's the
rest of the nfl it's the guys who aren't
starting quarterbacks it's the guys who
haven't been you know high caliber
football players for the team it's the
guys who've been making a minimum making
the league minimum uh maybe for one two
three years of their career and they
don't have enough money to stand on for
the next season to go about to where
that's where it gets scary and to what
you're saying too yeah football players
want to play football and i have a hard
time thinking that yes the union could
stick together that way and ultimately
strike for a better deal
i just don't know if that's feasible at
this point one here's part of the
problem as well you can tell players to
save their money now so they have money
in 2021
uh or wait yeah it would be the 2021
season right um you got a lot of guys
still in college that are going to be a
big chunk of the nfl come 2021 they're
not making money so they don't have any
money to save and it occurred to me
yesterday chris this is one of the ways
that the free farm system
that is college football it benefits the
nfl these guys aren't paid because they
have nothing to save so they have a
greater urgency to finally get paid to
finally cash in and they're going to be
less inclined to go along with the work
stoppage then and they're going to be a
significant chunk of the workforce when
the time comes because that happens
every year a certain percentage of the
nfl cycles out young guys cycle in and
those guys have no money and what are
they going to do to save money in 2019
and 2020 so that's a real factor as well
it does look guys
it's it's it's unfortunate
that that that's the case because it
really does create an imbalance and the
owners have a lot more leverage because
the owners can do without a season of
football they have other interests that
are generating money and they're going
to be owning the team a hell of a lot
longer than the players are playing
football that's right but uh i i just
hope that that that they avoid ever
having the kind of imbalance that
necessitates a work stoppage you know
two year uh eight years ago the the two
sides got a deal done right on the brink
of missing money missing regular season
preseason games it would have been
pre-season that would have been wiped
out this time around i'm hopeful they
get it done
but i i also think that maybe there
needs to be a bit of an adjustment in
the player's direction i think this deal
is too good for the owners in large part
because they've never complained about
if they're never complaining about it
that means it's a pretty good deal what
is it what what is it you know and
you're way more knowledgeable than i am
about this subject and some of the
discrepancies and things that go on here
what is it the one thing if you had a
look at to go oh the players should want
this changed or ask for this what what
is it that jumps out to you mike
i think you just want more money you
want more money and you want a higher
floor for what teams have to spend they
still can choose individually to keep a
lot of money in their pockets i would
want a higher salary floor and i would
want i would just want a greater
percentage of the the money that's
coming in or i'd also want to make i
want to guard very carefully against
efforts by the nfl to divert money
before they do the split they're trying
to do that with the la stadium where
they want to have more of the funds go
toward
paying for that and then do the split
and getting that credit and then do the
split that's what you have to be very
careful yeah and you know we talked
earlier in the week about the creative
accounting practices the buccaneers used
to try to get a piece of the deepwater
horizon
oil spill compensation fund the nfl will
use creative compensation when necessary
to try to get a better deal for
themselves so i think they have to be
very vigilant to ensure that they're
getting
a piece of the biggest pie possible get
the biggest piece of the biggest pie and
force the teams to spend more
uh by raising that salary floor people
talk about getting rid of salary cap
they get rid of sally kick for salary
cap to get rid of the salary floor and
you would have teams that would be going
with minimum salaries across the board
you want to force teams to spend more
money that's what i would try to do it
all comes down to getting more money in
the hands of the players they have a
limited window to play they have a
limited window to earn they take
significant physical risks the money is
i think the biggest thing and obviously
it's the biggest thing for ownership
it's why they're all in this yeah ready
for the money the money is the top
factor well yeah mike i mean and to your
point and just re you know hey you look
at there's 12 teams in football that
have 20 plus million dollars left on
their salary cap still and that's not
towards the teams at the top of the list
like the colts who are almost at 60
million dollars and the houston texans
at 40 and the 49ers at 35 so to your
point you're right i never really
thought about that but the the floor has
to raise you know that's a bunch of crap
to me right there that there's this many
unaccounted millions out there that
aren't going to the players that
ultimately are going to be pocketed by
the organization and the billion dollar
owner so uh good job by you i think you
have a a good day job you have a future
in this business way to go well and it
can and it can keep going up and up and
up each year too if you hover around
that minimum now you know every four
year and it gets very complicated very
quickly on a four-year rolling average
you have to spend 95 percent in cash of
the cap but still you you can pick and
choose when you're going to spend and
you can use creative accounting
practices and bottom line is you can
keep a lot of money in your pocket and
that's 60 million in cap space the cap
that the colts have that is money in the
pocket of jim irsay who can go buy john
lennon's piano and prince's guitar and
all sorts of other crap because it's 60
million dollars he's not spending on
making his football team as good as it
can be think of how much better they
would be if he had been spending that
money all along and getting good free
agents and bringing those people in and
making that team better and better
they'd be a potential dynasty
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports